michael is with us Michael's in Indiana
hey Michael welcome to the Dave Ramsey
show hi Dave thanks sir let me on sure
how can I help so I'm a freshman college
student and I have about 2/3 $20,000
saved up in the bank and I'm not looking
at paying too many large expenses
throughout college I don't want that
money just sitting there so what's the
best thing that I can do so that
benefits in the future how much do you
have left in college
I'm the freshman right now it's not
about for your stock okay
I do want it sitting there and here's
why okay oh it is an insurance policy
that is more valuable than the
investment that it could create it
insures that Michael is going to finish
school debt free and that Michaels gonna
finish school at least unless he gets
kicked out for some reason other than
money okay what are you studying
engineering phenomenal would you agree
with me that your value in the
marketplace the income that you could
earn is going to be dramatically
increased over what it is today when you
graduate yeah definitely
okay so mathematically the best
investment that Michael can make while
studying aerospace engineering is to
make sure he completes that degree you
will that's a much greater rate of
return than any mutual fund will pay
mm-hm you are a better investment than a
mutual fund is yes so long as well I
will be working at a co-op this summer
and fall that will be paying in total
about $25,000 you still recommend
holding on to all of them or yes I don't
care if you got a hundred thousand
dollars piled up I want to ensure you
get out of there with your skin intact
and graduated and no debt and because
listen here's that any ground you lose
on that money in the next two years or
so which is really what we're really
talking about you will make up very
quickly when you get out with a sizeable
income and taking that money
and using it for your transition when
you get out because here's what happens
typically that doesn't always happen but
if you're in let's say you're sitting on
50 grand okay you graduate with an
aerospace engineering degree in three
years
it's it's not unusual at all for you to
take a new job and move that costs money
and it's not unusual at all that in the
next 36 months that you're married it's
not required
I'm just saying statistically it's not
unusual and oh by the way there's
probably a car that needs to be
purchased about that time so you're
gonna need some money to set your life
up when you come out if everything goes
perfectly
hmm and that and this money sets you in
there and then from there on you're in a
position and my prediction is you're
gonna be making six figures and my
prediction is is that you'll be a
millionaire by the time you're 30 but
yeah if you follow the stuff I'm talking
about that's where you should be even
though we did not get really
sophisticated with our investing of this
money while you were in school because
we're gonna make sure that Michael gets
this degree without debt and that is
worth more than any mutual fund okay
just saying dude you asked my opinion
you're an analytical guy you're a guy's
good with numbers so it's easy to get
caught up in the math Theory here but
what I'm giving you is kind of horse
sense here but it actually works out
mathematically by the way which horse
sense usually does